hello good morning welcome to Thursday
so when I left uni I kind of had this
idea that being a data scientist meant I
was gonna sit in front of a computer and
tune models all day right like I'd have
these well-defined problems I'd have
nice datasets and my job was basically
to be effectively a cook you know a
professional kaggle competitor it turns
out I was wrong and we've learned a
bunch of things over the last few years
shipping data products they send us we
should provide quite a few and we've
grown the team a fair bit and I think
this talk is going to kind of cover some
of the things that we've learned along
the way
I think shipping data product is very
much more than just building models
models are an important part of this but
they're also just a small part of what
it takes to get an idea that's gonna be
powered by machine learning out in front
of customers engage with and actually
being used so I will also give a caveat
that I'm giving this talk but it
actually represents the work of many
amazing people who are not me and who
are not here today so I'm just kind of
the messenger in this case so first
things first let me give some context
I'm Chris I manage the data science team
at Zendesk I've been there for about
five years I guess
linking back to Miguel's talk yesterday
we run sort of a hybrid model so we're
centralized and embedded at the same
time partly because we're geographically
distributed so we're in Copenhagen San
Francisco and in Melbourne so we get all
of the time zones which is incredibly
fun and challenging but it's also really
cool to be able to engage with so many
different parts of the business if you
don't know what a Zendesk is basically
we build a family of products that help
organizations to understand their
customers improve communication and
offer support when and where it's needed
and support is kind of historically our
core business but what we've branched
out quite a bit beyond that
more recently so I'd send us I think we
we really believe that you know we we
capture really interesting datasets we
have an amazing like an amazing view of
how companies interact with their
customers across the world and we also
really believe that we we can use this
information to build better product and
build better customer experiences so
just a bit more context today I'm just
gonna walk you through briefly three
products we've built over the past years
have been powered by machine learning
they're gonna come up throughout the
talk so the first one is answer baat
anta blood at a high level is basically
this idea is to allow people submitting
support requests to self solve their
questions so you send in a request we
use machine learning to match that
against knowledgebase articles that the
company has and give you the ability to
close out the ticket without an agent
having to be involved and this is really
useful for the for the for the end user
for the submitter because they don't
have to wait in queue you know for an
agent to get to the request which
sometimes can be days they get an answer
immediately there's also great for the
agents because they don't have to answer
the same questions over and over again
and they can spend their time helping
customers who really need that more
hands-on experience another product that
we ship recently earlier this year is
called content queues and the idea
behind content queues is to give context
to content creators so in our guide
product which is our knowledge based
product you know people write Help
Center articles and the question is
where should I spend my time where
should I focus what articles should I
write so content queues basically takes
all of the support tickets at your that
your company is getting we costed them
together we generate summarizations for
that and we can service that information
up to the content creators so that they
can create better and more targeted
articles and think about where they
should be spending their time the final
product I want to talk about briefly is
called satisfaction prediction this is
the first machine learning product we
shipped the idea here basically is to
predict whether or not a support
experience is going to end up with a
good or a bad outcome before that
actually happens and then you can use
those scores it's kind of like a
sentiment analysis but a slightly
fancier than that but basically you can
use those scores to drive business
automation to in to engage with with
support cases that look like they're
turning bad before they actually close
out and so you can do something to sort
of turn them around so they're three
products that we've built over the last
couple of years and I'm going to talk
about a couple of areas I think that I
sort of like there weren't obvious to me
when I started out as a data scientist
that became really important parts of
building these products I mean I talked
about how data product is still building
product the importance of investing in
infrastructure the importance of being
able to learn to learn as a team
why scaling is
always and why user experiences is a
super important and probably underrated
part of actually building machine
learning powered product so data
products are still product I think one
thing that wasn't obvious to me coming
out of university is why everyone
wouldn't just want to use machine
learning for all the things all the time
right
and then you turn up in a company and
you realize that a company has a huge
amount of priorities right and you know
there's all of these places you could
apply machine learning but doing machine
learning just for machine learnings sake
is not gonna be enough to get by and to
actually make that happen to build data
product to build a data products team so
you really need you know to get
organizational buy-in to get on a
product roadmap and to actually get
prioritized against all of the other
really important things that a company
needs to do you need to be able to sell
why you think the thing that you want to
build this data product is gonna be
really valuable and it's particularly
challenging for machine learning because
machine learning also brings with it
like a high level of uncertainty right
you start out on a machine learning
project and you don't know in advance
whether you're going to be able to build
a model that's gonna be successful for
the problem you're trying to solve right
it's research so it's unknown if it
wasn't it wouldn't be as fun and
interesting but it also makes it a
harder selling point so I think the way
we think about this and the way we get
around it is to speak to the business
the way that everyone else speaks with
business about product so we treat
building data product just like any
other product and there's kind of three
there's kind of three things that we
think about in this like three main
takeaways I think one is to start with
the customer you know and and I think
this is key to building any consumer
facing product right what are the
problems they're facing and what do you
think it is that you can do that's
actually gonna help them what's the
value you're gonna provide and you want
to be really clear about what that
impact is and why it's gonna be valuable
um once you have a good understanding of
what that means you should really start
digging into your data and think about
how can i frame our hypothesis around
this how would I test this how do I
measure success what does the metric
look like and then do I have the data to
actually answer those questions because
if you don't you need to start getting
that data and once you've really you've
you know you've done well to frame this
problem of what it is you're trying to
impact and how you're gonna measure your
impact then it's kind of getting to the
agile side of things be iterative
iterate and start moving towards that
and and I think with data product you
know there's all these fancy algorithms
you can use but you really want to start
simple it is amazing and Despres
seeing how often a heuristic or you know
a simple tree and if-then-else statement
will actually help get you a long way to
solving a problem that looks really hard
from the outset right and there's a
machine learning research person that's
kind of depressing but it you know from
a product delivery perspective it's
amazing because if then else statements
are substantially less complex than
building a neural net and so I think
like once you once you go down that path
the the I think the advantage of having
sort of thought about what your customer
value is and how you're going to measure
success is that when you start with you
heuristic your simple thing and you
notice that it doesn't work as well as
you need for the product right you've
got this really clear value proposition
around why you might want to use machine
learning to start closing that gap so
you're measuring this thing and we need
to get this metric from here to here but
you know the heuristic only gets us
halfway so we need to do something more
to make this viable and that's that puts
you in a position that's much easier to
sell the investment in to machine
learning doesn't take aways I'm thinking
about product that I that I think about
you want to be really clear about how
you're gonna measure success you want to
work with your product manager if you're
lucky enough to have one and always sort
of come back to your customer value and
I think this is something that we've
found to be really successful both in
sort of communicating and getting buy-in
for the ideas that we have around how we
can use machine learning to impact our
product but also in scrapping a whole
bunch of ideas we had around how we
could use machine learning to impact our
product as you go through this process
and you realize this cool thing over
here where I have lots of data where
it's a really interesting ml product
when we play it out actually the impact
on the customer is not gonna be amazing
you know so let's do something else that
spend our time better investing in data
infrastructure again coming from you
know research backgrounds doing a PhD
you're kind of you're often the person
who is in command of all of the things
you get to build pull your own data sets
you do all of the data wrangling you do
all of the stuff right and so again it
wasn't obvious to me moving in the
industry afterwards that this kind of
had to change to actually make like data
products scalable and robust and
something that you can ship and put in
front of people a data product requires
infrastructure and it requires
infrastructure that is often different
to the infrastructure that the rest of
the business has you know data lakes
clearly you need your data from
somewhere also ability to serve your
machine learning models in production
all of these things are really important
and I think a thing that we sort of
learned over the last few years is a
great way to get investment for this
stuff is to tie it to customer value
right tied to something that the
business wants to see so for us a good
example of this was five years ago we
started the data team right and a data
team needs data so we started looking
into how we would actually get data to
start building data product and we
realized that the thing that it made
Zend us successful at scaling
horizontally - you know our fast-growing
customer base was the thing that was
really in our way as a data products
team so this fancy picture here
basically gives you an overview of what
our data architecture looks like in
production and without going into detail
effectively the way we scale
horizontally is to shout our databases
so we can just keep adding more and more
database shards as we get more and more
customers this is amazingly useful and
efficient for scaling for you know more
and more companies using Zendesk but
it's terrible from the from a data
analysis and a data product perspective
because you're there's no single place
to go to to get all of your data and so
if I ask the first thing that we had to
build of this team was not machine
learning product was not like some fancy
thing it was actually go and build a
data Lake so we could get our data so we
could set ourselves up for success we
really need to get that in order to make
it work and I guess like back back in
the day this was five years ago when we
started building it this our approach to
building a data Lake was all bare metal
it was her do it had closure in it it
was pull based so we'd reach out to all
of these shards every single day and
pull in all of the changes that had
happened to build up snapshots of what
the world looked like luckily I think
we've moved forward from that these days
we're in AWS it's all a push based
system we use this really cool service
called Maxwell if you're interested you
should go and check it out it's open
sourced by us and basically the idea
behind Maxwell is it listens to the
binary logs over my sequel server and
every time a change happens into my
sequel database it's written out into
the binary logs like it's like the
history of all the stuff that's happened
to the database Maxwell basically slurps
that up and throws it into Kafka topics
for you so that you can then from our
perspective from it from a daylight
perspective we have EMR jobs that run in
AWS that that read from those Kathryn
topics roll that all back up into it
into sort of the state of the world
right so we now have this single place
where we can go and query all of the
data across all of our database shards
in one place using things like spark
sequel
or athina which is sort of our tools of
choice at the moment so this was a
really big engineering investment right
like the first iteration of our data
Lake and the second iteration of our
data Lake there's there's a lot of
engineering work that goes into that and
there was not really much machine
learning work that goes into that but to
make we had to make that happen to build
up a bit like our data products team and
the way that we got buy-in to that was
to build something together with this
that the company really cared about from
a product perspective and in this case
it was what you see on the screen here
it's called benchmarks and basically the
premise here is it gives support
organization the ability to compare how
they operate you know what their metrics
are for their support organization so
customer satisfaction full resolution
time first reply time all these things
to industry standards across other
people other companies using Zendesk and
so I kind of think of benchmarks as as
the Trojan horse that got us to be able
to build ml products right like so
benchmarks got us a data Lake after that
we built satisfaction prediction and as
a byproduct of that we got the ability
to serve machine learning models in
production after that we built answer
bottom we got the ability to do natural
language understanding and serve neural
nets in production and so we've kind of
we've kind of framed all about
infrastructure investments around
investing in products that that the
company cares about and it doesn't
always have to be something fancy I
think some of the things that came after
this you know had a lot more ml in it
and and you know we're a bit fancier but
benchmarks are super straightforward I
think from a from a mathematical
perspective right there's basics to
aggregate statistics happening here but
the customer value was enough that it
was worth the investment and it got us a
data Lake and that was pretty awesome so
I think two takeaways one is obviously
you need data infrastructure and you
should have be investing in that the
other is that your infrastructure
investments a great way to get buy-in
from that for your company if you if
you're if you're finding that hard is to
tie it to a customer something that
provides customer value and it doesn't
have to be anything fancy but yeah
getting that buy-in is gonna make the
whole process and getting resourcing a
lot easier
water break okay
learning to learn I think this is like
if there's one takeaway from all of
these things this is the one right like
I think it's a recurring theme in
everything that we've ever done it's
probably a recurring theme in your daily
lives and and most people who come into
the data science space know how to teach
themselves stuff it's kind of a it's a
weird sort of collection of people from
all sorts of different backgrounds right
but I think I dog you'd like the number
one skill for a data scientist and for a
data science team is being able to learn
new things and it's because the research
is moving so fast like the state of the
art in the field both from a research
perspective but also a tooling
perspectives is constantly changing and
if you can't get good as learning not
just individually but together at a team
in ups as a team and upskilling each
other that's going to be a real big
challenge for you sort of as you go out
and try and build you know what can be
quite complex and challenging data
products so a great example of this for
us was building answer button so answer
but at a high level kind of does this
right you send in a support request like
you see on the left here it was
originally designed to respond to emails
so someone writes in an email asking
sort of a question about some problem
they're having and we want to build some
sort of fancy machine learning to match
that to a knowledgebase article that
exists and this is doesn't necessarily
sound hard because it's kind of like
search but it's a bit harder than search
because in this case the thing that
they're asking about is dumping our
ticket data but that's kind of buried in
this really long-form email right so
throwing it into elasticsearch or
something like this is just going to
fail miserably so it's it's a very
similar premise but there's you know a
whole bunch of ml you need to do to
actually make this make this possible
and at the time and we were building
this we started with classical ml and
there's a few reasons for that one is
I'm a big believer in do the simplest
thing first and and see if it fails the
other is that you know deep learning
hadn't really gained a lot of traction
in the inner and the NLP space at that
point in time so kind of the the
baseline back then was do tf-idf and
throw it into an SVM or a logistic
regression and and it kind of it kind of
worked right we had a lot of labeled
data but as we started down this path we
started learning very quickly that we
were running into challenges some of
them were we didn't have an even spread
of data so for a particular customer
maybe they have a hundred knowledgebase
articles
we would only have say ten articles that
had good a good number of example
tickets that map to that article right
so a good number of labeled examples and
the other ninety articles didn't have
much data so we didn't really know how
to learn a model for that cold start
problem is a huge thing when you're
building product for four consumers
right and you're using supervised
learning if you if you don't know the
cold start problem is it's basically you
get a new customer you don't have any
data for them so you don't know how to
build a model right and there's some lag
in time between when someone starts with
you and when you can actually make the
product successful for them in in our
case there's two ways that happens one
is it's a completely new customer to
Zendesk the other is it's an existing
customer Zendesk who maybe has changed
an existing knowledgebase article or
created a new article where we now need
to wait some period of time before we
have enough data to make that work all
of those things don't make for a great
customer experience and so we spent a
few months going down this path both
from the research perspective and from
the engineering side so how we would
actually build this and get it into
production and put it in front of
customers and we basically hit a dead
end
from from the research side of things we
realized we could not make these models
work well enough to make the product
sort of a good value proposition so we
had to pivot and to where the learning
comes in and we threw away a lot of work
right and we had to start fresh as a
team and we had to upskill as a team
none of us really had a background in
neuro nets none of us really had a
background in NLP and it was really it
was really hard we had to go and read a
lot of things we had to like together
learn how to use a bunch of new
frameworks and sort of start driving a
research agenda that we didn't really
understand and it was hard and there was
about a billion times where we thought
we were gonna fail miserably and then
like all good research it's like failing
failing failing failing boo it works and
we were happy and I think you know from
a technical perspective we we ended up
with rolling our own fast text
embeddings passing that through l STM's
and some fully connected layers and we
end up with basically the ability the
ability to embed both the tickets that
come in and also the Articles that might
answer them and the idea is that the
tickets and the answering article are
close together so we can just do
distance space metrics and that was
quite nice and it becomes a nice
solution for the product because we end
up with one global model that can serve
all of our customers we get away from
the cold start problem because we have a
global model we don't need training data
for your new customer and that
actually made made the product a lot
more viable than it would have been from
a supervised learning perspective but
none of that would have been possible if
we weren't able to learn as a team and
so I have some thoughts about ways to
make learning part of your culture I
think the first one and it's a really
important point is creating a safe space
learning new things means having new
ideas right and it also means being
wrong or what and a team really needs
tonight an environment where they can
bounce ideas off each other where they
can interject where they can collaborate
and that's only gonna happen if they
feel like they have emotional safety
right if they feel like they're not
gonna be cold out or chastised for
having a wrong idea or a poor idea right
that's like research doesn't work like
that there's a billion poor ideas and
then there's a good one and people only
remember the good one
you need you really need an environment
to enable that and I think without that
you don't have a research team you have
a bunch of researchers sitting next to
each other and I don't think that's
going to get you to be at being able to
solve the hard problems that they come
up in front of you the second point I
think is around running a journal club
or a paper club right this is something
we've done since the inception of the
team every week we get together and we
talk about a particular paper that we've
seen in research or maybe we spend a few
weeks deep diving into a theme like
reinforcement learning or natural
language understanding building that
muscle on how to learn was something
that was like really important for us
and it helped us a huge amount when we
got to this point where we had to learn
a whole bunch of new things and now like
our product kind of depended on it right
and the final one I think is get
research try and get your research as
far ahead of engineering as possible we
had to pivot and throw away a bunch of
research but we also our engineers also
had to throw away a bunch of
infrastructure that they had written to
support that research right and so it's
kind of like it was doubly impactful
from from the amount of wasted work I
think pivoting is really important right
and it's it's kind of a given if you're
doing research you're gonna run into
things that just don't work and have to
try new things
the further you can get out in front of
engineering and sort of reduce that
uncertainty by the time you need to
build the infrastructure that's going to
support that I think the better from a
product delivery perspective scaling
scaling is hard taking an idea that
works for one customer or making it work
for lots of customers is hard it's hard
if you're doing an app it's hard if
you're doing machine learning it's hard
if you're doing basically anything
um in my mind I think when it comes to
data product this kind of two categories
of scaling one is the build more things
approach this is kind of like you know
you need to build a model per account
for some particular machine learning
problem so you need to take an approach
to building a model and you need to just
maybe build thousands of them instead of
one of them and the other is make a
single model do more things so that's
kind of like answer part right we needed
to make a single model work for all of
our customers and so it's challenging
from a research perspective but not so
much from an infrastructure and scaling
perspective on the side of building more
things to examples of that for us
satisfaction prediction and content
queues both of those products require us
to build a model per account and we have
more than 145,000 companies that pay to
use send us so you can imagine there's a
lot of model building that goes on there
right I think there's a few things that
like a few key points in in making that
work one is you need to automate the
data scientist out of loop there is no
way you can employ enough data
scientists to go and hand-tuned 145,000
models right and even if you could
actually find all of those people you
certainly couldn't afford to pay them so
you need to be able to come up with a
way of actually tuning those models and
validating that they're good enough and
shipping them to production that doesn't
involve a human actually looking at them
and the other thing is that the runtime
performance and memory usage of those
models this can become super important
right because if you build one model and
it takes five hours to build okay that's
fine but you you know you multiply that
by a hundred thousand and that's a
realistically large amount of time that
you probably don't want to pay for
compute for right so so I think like
those two things are really important
things to think about when you're trying
to scale your model building the other
thing is that you need to invest in some
infrastructure actually make this happen
back in the day we had to do all sorts
of weird things to make her do this for
us luckily these days we we're happy
users of AWS batch which is amazing for
this sort of thing you can queue up your
jobs it goes and does the compute for
you and writes all of the output to to
s3 it's very nice
there's a really good series of blog
posts if you're interested a little bit
more in how we use AWS batch to build
and serve machine learning models just
go and search for AWS batch Zendesk
machine learning you'll you'll find it
and it dives into a lot more technical
detail about how this works
ronger make one model do more things sad
I think this is a less obvious approach
to scaling but it's definitely something
that comes up a lot something that came
up again in answer but I said before
that we you know we built this one
global model France apart and that was
amazing we didn't have to build a model
core account actually what we built was
one global model for all of our
customers in English and it turns out we
support a lot more languages in English
and so we didn't really have a global
model and we were back to trying to work
out how to actually build more models
again the way we approach this at the
moment in production is literally to
build more machine learning models so a
ticket comes in we do some sort of
language detection and based on the
detection of the language we route it to
the particular in your net model that
that we need to do the embedding but
there's only scales so far right because
we don't necessarily have enough data in
some of those languages to be able to
train a model of the complexity that we
use for English and Spanish and
Portuguese right so we start we start
running into some constraints around how
far we can actually go in supporting the
long tail of languages that people use
in Zendesk recently we've been
experimenting a lot using muse
embeddings if you haven't heard of them
they're pre-trained embeddings that come
out of facebook historically we didn't
have much luck with pre-trained
embeddings and we kind of had to roll
our own muse seems to work really well
for us actually at least so far we're
kind of in the testing phase at the
moment but I think the really
interesting thing that Muse provides is
that the embeddings are aligned between
languages right so like the word for dog
is embedded to exactly this give or take
the same space in English as it is in
German as it is in French as it is in
Portuguese or Japanese and that's super
useful because we can actually use that
to just build up one big dictionary of
like all the words in the world and
train a single neural net to be able to
do and support for us instead of having
multiples and that seems to work quite
okay but there's still two trade-offs on
that like one is that you need to build
a really big dictionary and you need to
host that in memory and that is painful
sometimes and the other is that we still
run into another challenge 4n support
which is called out of vocabulary so a
lot of a lot of companies have products
that have weird names and they don't
tend to turn up in you know dictionaries
of the English language and if they're
not in the dictionary we don't know how
to embed them so we don't know what to
do with them so a part that we're
starting down now
is looking at building single character
models that don't have a dictionary and
trying to build those for multiple
languages we're very much at the
beginning of that if any of you work in
that space please come and talk to me in
office hours I would love to pick your
brain yeah I think takeaways from
scaling getting from one to many
customers is hard
always fact scaling needs tooling and
you should really think about the
investment of that upfront and global
models are great if you can build a
global model you don't have to build a
hundred thousand individual models you
should do that and sometimes it's worth
the trade-off you might have in
performance and so you know you're
always giving up something to build a
global model but you know if you're also
saving yourself six months of
engineering investment to make the other
product out the door that's not
necessarily a bad trade-off alright the
last thing I want to talk about was user
experience for the win I think this is
overlooked a lot but the user experience
is really where the rubber hits the road
for you machine learning model right is
how people engage with your models and
you can build the best model in the
world that predicts all things perfectly
if no one looks at it no one does
anything with it
no one cares right we learned this with
answer bot when we first built our
neural net models friend support we
wanted to start getting validation from
from real people around how well they
were performing and so our first part of
this was to build what's called a
sidebar app in Zendesk so you can see an
example of one here with answers
suggested and the idea was that you know
an agent would be on a support ticket
and we would be suggesting articles on
the right-hand side and hopefully they
would give us feedback about whether
those articles were good or bad so it
turns out the thing that we missed there
like amazing implementation very nice
and neat right back you can you could
totally interact with that and see what
it does
the thing that we missed from a user
experience perspective is that agents
have a really well-defined workflows and
asking them to change their workflow and
look at a new piece of information is
actually something that is really hard
right they've got KPIs around how they
need to do their support performance how
quickly they need to answer tickets they
get into a flow and asking them to do
something different to what they were
doing before requires a lot of
convincing additionally most sendest
instances don't look like that with a
single app on the side but you're
competing for space against a whole
other a bunch of other useful apps that
are part of their workflows already and
so what ended up happening with this is
we shipped it to production and no one
engage with it because
it was different to what they needed to
be using in support and so we got no
feedback on our models which was poor
because that's what we wanted to do this
for we kind of got around that by going
in hand labeling a whole bunch of data
ourselves it was a good stopgap in the
short term but I think we really missed
the the UX optimization there later we
once we got confident with that we
started putting the models out in front
of people and so this is what the what
the the answer what experience looks
like now you get a customer question we
suggest some answers and you get this
button that says just close my request
right and when we put that out in front
of people the idea is you know the more
often people click yes close my requests
the better the model is and we can use
this to actually work out how good we're
doing and suggesting the right article
but when we first shipped this we didn't
say yes close my request we had a button
that said sold my request and people
clicked on that a lot when we put the
when we put them up when we put as about
at first and we thought that actually
meant that our models were doing
amazingly and then we got suspicious
because it was doing really really well
and then when we dug into it it turned
out that we had different expectations
around what that button actually meant
from our perspective it was we've
suggested the article to you you found
the right answer to your problem and
you're clicking this button because you
want to close your ticket and tell us
that we've done well from the end-user
perspective what they thought that
button meant was I clicked that button
and someone reaches out to me and
they're gonna they're gonna help me
solve my question right so we had a
mismatch in what we thought that button
meant and the wording was really
important because we ended up measuring
something that was not what we thought
it was we got no real feedback on what
our model was actually doing so my
takeaways on the UX side is it doesn't
matter how good your model is it no one
engages with it nobody cares you need to
be really conscious of making your
interactions with machine learning
models clear because you're relying on
that feedback and if the people giving
the feedback are giving you feedback
that doesn't match with what you're
expecting that that feedback to mean
you're not actually learning anything
and it can be really dangerous because
you can send you in completely the wrong
direction and the last one is kind of
like I think from my from my side of
things I personally believe machine
learning should never get in the way if
you're building machine learning product
machine learning is never right 100% of
the time so you really want to be able
to build that the user experience in a
way that when it is right you're
providing value and when it's not right
you're not getting in the way of the end
user
down okay so that was like a journey
through a bunch of stuff that we've done
over like the last five years I think
hopefully you agree with me that there
is a lot more to building data product
than just building models certainly this
is kind of like a note to my old self
from graduating uni days that there is a
lot more involved in this and there's a
lot more people involved in making it
actually go I think hopefully some of
those lessons are useful things and you
can get some takeaways from those I'm
happy to talk about any of this and more
in the office hours this is my thank you
slide you'll notice in the small text on
the side that says we're hiring you can
ask me about that too
Cheers
[Applause]